في سنه 2006 في زوجين بولنديين اسمهم مارك
وماجور ساترزيسكي حبوا يشتروا بيت في
ضواحي العاصمه وعرس كانوا منتظرين طفل
فكانوا محتاجين مساحه اكبر من سكنهم
الحالي وحديقه خاصه عشان الطفل يلعب فيها
طبعا هنشتري البيت منين ولا ازاي راحوا
البنك فاقترح الموظف عليهم انهم يعملوا
سيئه الاف البولنديين الثانيين اللي
اشتروا منازل من خلال رهن العقاري ولكن
بعمل اجنبيه هي الفرنك السويسري مش العمله
المحليه اللي هي زلوله البولندي علشان
يستفيدوا من اسعار الفائده المنخفضه في
سويسرا مقارنه بولندا وهنعرف بعد شويه مع
بعض ببساطه يعني ايه رهن عقاري المهم مالك
وماجوسات اشتروا البيت الف مبروك لكن ما
حدش نبههم وقتها لحاجه خطيره جدا جدا وهي
عواقب التغير في اسعار الصرف كان كل
معتمدين على فكره استقرار الفرنك السويس
قصاد العمله المحليه وبالتالي ما فيش
مشاكل لكن البعض كان خايف من وبيعتبره
كابوس حصل بالفعل وارتفع الفرنك السويسري
امام سلوتي البولندي وجميع عملات دول شرق
ووسط اوروبا اللي كان منتشر فيها النوع ده
من قروض الرهن العقاري بالفرنك السويسري
وبالتالي الزوجين البولنديين والاف الاسر
غيرهم سواء في بولندا او غيرها لقوا ديون
الرهن العقاري بتاعتهم تضخمت جدا وبقت
اضعاف قيمه العقار نفسه فدوه الجوله
للمحاكم الهولنديه علشان تنجدهم من الورطه
دي فالمكم بدات تحكم لهم وتحمل البنك
نتائج رهنه على الاستثمار بالعمله
السويسريه هنا البنوك لقت نفسها بتلبس في
الحيط وبعضهم اوشك على الانهيار واعلان زي
بنك جت النوبل اللي انهار من كم اسبوع في
اكبر تهديد بيواجه القطاع المصرفي دلوقت
في بولندا تحديدا اللي هي اكبر اقتصاد في
شرق اوروبا وبعض دول شرق ووسط القاره بشكل
عام قنبله منتظر انفجارها في اي لحظه
البعد بيشوف انهار جاءت النوبل كان اول
قطع الدومينو تقع في سلسه الانهيار
المتوقع يتبعه بنقطع وهنا لازم نسال شويه
اسئله مهمه جدا زي مثلا ايه اللي بيحصل
بالضبط في بولندا وللبنوك بدات تنهار هناك
وايه قصه بنك جيت النوبل اللي انهار من
اسابيع ده وازاي اصلا بدات كارثه الرهون
العقاريه بالفرنكس 3 وايه اللي الحكومات
بتفكر فيه علشان تمنع الكارثه الماليه دي
قبل ما الدنيا تتطبق على دماغه الكل دي
عينه من الاسئله المثيره اللي هنحاول
نجاوب عليها مع بعض في حلقه النهارده وقبل
ما نبدا عاوز افكركم زي كل مره انه تقريبا
نصف مشاهدينا مش مشتركين في القناه لحد
وقت تصوير الحلقه دي اشتراكم واحد من اهم
اسباب مساعدتنا على الاستمرار في تقديم
محتوى المخبر الاقتصادي بنفس الجوده
وتطويره دائما فباطلب من اللي لسه ما
اشتركش في القناه منكم انه مشاري وفعلوا
الجرس التنبيهات علشان تتابعوا كل حلقه
جديده ان شاء الله يلا بينا انا اشرف
ابراهيم انا الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
الحلقه دي برعايه شركه ايفرتون تقدر تحصل
على اهم ادوات التداول اللي بيحتاجها اي
متداول محترف وبالتالي تحصل على حوريه
اكبر
تسع ادوات متقدمه متخصصه هتخليك اقرب
لتحقيق اهدافك هتلاقي رابط لهم تحت
الفيديو في التعليقات فيسبوك الرهن
العقاري باختصار ببساطه علشان حضراتكم
تكونوا في الصوره هو نوع من انواع القروض
بيتم استخدامه في شراء عقار بدون دفع ثمنه
بالكامل مقدما يعني اللي بيحصل ان المقترض
بيدفع للبنك مبلغ الاصلي هو العقاري هنا
بالاضافه للفائده على المبلغ ده على اقساط
متقسمه على مدد زمنيه طويله وبيمتلك
العقار اللي بيكون ضمان لتامين القرض يعني
لو المقترض تعثر وما قدرش يسدد الاقساط
البنك بيحط يده على العقار ويبيعه وبيسترد
ديون رهن العقاري بتاعته اللي على المقطع
ده طيب كل اللي فات ده مفهوم المشاكل كلها
بقى بتبدا تظهر لما يكون القرض ده بعمل
اجنبيه او نقوم معامل اجنبيه فايه اللي
يخلي اي انسان يروح ياخذ قرض بعمله غير
عمله بلده المحليه الاجابه ببساطه علشان
يستفيد من انخفاض اسعار الفائده طب ازاي
ده حصل هاقول لك القواعد التنظيميه
والقانونيه في بلدان شرق وسط اوروبا كانت
بتسمح للبنوك في حاله معدلات الفائده
المرتفعه على العمله المحليه انهم يقدموا
قروض اما بعمل اجنبيه او قروض مربوطه بعمل
اجنبيه هنا المحتردين على المدى القصير
هيستفيده لانهم هيقدروا يوصلوا لقروض بضغط
على سعر فائده اقل ولكن على المدى الطويل
لو المقترض كان دخله بالعمله المحليه
ولكنه اخذ قرض بعمله اجنبيه فاكيد انعجله
او اجلا هيتعرض لمخاطر مرتبطه بتغير اسعار
الصرف وبالذات لو كان القرض من نوعيه
القروض طويله الاجل زي القروده رهن
العقاري اللي بيتم سدادها على مدى 25 و30
سنه واحيانا اكثر من كده نرجع بقى لمنطقه
شرق ووسط اوروبا اللي فيها القروض
العقاريه المقاومه بالعمله الاجنبيه وهي
الفرانك السويسري بنتكلم تقريبا عن اواخر
2004 لما بدات القروض دي تنتشر بشكل كبير
جدا في دول زي اليونان وكرواتيا والمجر
والنمسا وبولندا ورومانيا سلوفينيا وفي
دولتين ثانيين من خارج الاتحاد الاوروبي
هم الجبل الاسود وسربيا طب ليه قروض
الفرانك السويسري تحديدا كان لها شعبيه
كبيره والبنوك مركزه عليها لانه كان
معروفه عن سويسرا له عقود طويله انها
بتتمتع بادنى معدلات فائده في العالم
وكانت بتتفاخر بحاجه زي كده وبالتالي كانت
القروض بالفلانكس مصر بالنسبه للمستهلكين
اول مقترضين سواء في بولندا او غيرها من
المفترضين في اوروبا الشرقيه وسيله للهروب
من تكاليف الاقتراضنا المرتفعه في بلدانهم
الاصليه على سبيل المثال في بولندا سنه
2008 كانت البنوك بتاخذ فائده على قروض
الفرنك السويسري حوالي 4.2% في المقابل
كانت الفائده على القروض بالعمله المحليه
هي الثانويه البولندي بتوصل ل 8.7% يعني
اكثر من ضعف معدل الفائده على قروض الفرنك
السويسري مش كده بس بعد الازمه الماليه
العالميه ما حصلت في 2008 تكاليف لقطارات
في الدول الغربيه انخفضت جدا ووصلت لصفر
في بعض الدول وبالتالي انخفضت اسعار
الفائده على قروض الفرنك السويسري اكتر
وصلت لاثنين فاصل 7% بس في 2010 وبالتالي
فرق الفائده ده كان له تاثير مباشر على
الاقساط الشهريه اللي كان بيدفعها مقترض
رهن العقاري وخلونا نوضح ده مثال بسيط
ولكن قبلها عاوز اقول لكم ان قروض
الفلانكس سويسري مش معناها ان المقترض كان
بيستلم فرانكس وسرف يده لا هو كان بيستلم
عمله المحليه عادي اللي هي هنا لو بنتكلم
عن بولندا
لكنها عمله مقاومه بالفرنسي يعني بنشوف
سعر الصرف كم وبنحسب على اساسه وهكذا
واحنا بنصدد الاقساط بنشوف سعر الصرف كان
وبندفع القسط يعني لو انا كنت محتاج كبير
وبعد ما دورت العيد كويس ومناسب سالت على
سعره قالوا لي 300,000 زولته بولند مثلا
هنا هاروح للبنك واخذ قرض رهن عقاري لكن
البنك هيقول لي قدامك خيارين الاول تاخذ
قرض عادي بالفائده العاليه في بولندا
والخيار الثاني تاخد قرض فرانك سويسري
بفايده اقل وده اللي احنا بنرشحه لك فلو
اخدت قرض زانوتي بولندي هتدفع 2100 زولتي
بولند في الشهر لو اخذت قرض فرانك سويسري
هتدفع 1400 سليتي بولند بس فط طبيعي
ومنطقي انت هتروح للمبلغ الاقل وبالذات مع
استقرار سعر الصرف بين الفرانكس سويسري
وسلوك البولندي الفتره طويله ودخل الناس
اللي ما كانتش بتفكر تشتري بيوت تبدا تفكر
تستغل الفرصه وتاخذ قروض رهن عقاري مقاومه
بالفرنسي سويسري وبالتالي انتشرت قروض
الفرنك سويسرا بشكل كبير جدا
سنه 2011 وصلت قيمه القروض المقاومه
بالعملات الاجنبيه 54 مليار دولار بنتكلم
على الان 40% يحفظك قروض البنوك التجاريه
في بولندا كانت قروض مقاومه بعملات اجنبيه
ثلثين القروض دي كانت قروض فرانكس وسويسري
كانت هي المنتج الرئيسي في السوق بالنسبه
للبنوك تلف الايام والاوضاع تبدا تتغير
بشكل جيد بعد ما الازمه الماليه ضربت
الاقتصاد العالمي في 2008 ونهارت بعض
البنوك الامريكيه بعدها بدا المستثمرين في
العالم يجروا على الفرانك سويسري باعتباره
ملاذ امن من التراب السوق فارتفعت قيمته
مقابل جميع العملات بما فيهم عملات دول
شرق ووسط اوروبا زي الظلوط البولندي
والفاره المجري والكونه الكرواتيه وغيرهم
وجاءت الضربه الكبرى الحامله الرجوله
العقاريه بالفرنك السويسري في 15 يناير
2015 لما سويسرا فك ارتباط الفرنك
السويسري باليورو فرتفع قيمه الفرنك 20%
وبالتالي قيمه ترتفعت اكثر قدام عملات دول
شرق وسط اوروبا وهنا كانت الكارثه تعالوا
نشوف اسعار الصرف قبل الكلام ده وبعده
علشان تعرفوا حجم المسلحه
يعني الفرانك سويسري مش مكمل اثنين زوتي
بولندي ومستقر بقى له فتره على الحل ده
بعد الازمه الماليه العالميه وصل الفرنك
سويسري في 2009 ل 3.2 بولاندي وبعد فكر
ارتباط الفرنك باليورو في 2015 ارتفع
الفرانك مره ثانيه وصل ل 4.2 بولانتي يعني
اكثر من ضعف قيمته في الفتره اللي انتشرت
فيها قروض الفرنك السويسري ودلوقتي وقت
تصوير الحلقه فرانك سويسري وصل ل 4.7
ثلاته يبقى عندي طب ليه القفزات الكبيره
في سعر الصرف بين الفرانكس وسويسري وبائع
عملات دول اوروبا زي السلوطي البولندي كان
شيء كراسي لان معظم قروض الرهن العقاري
كانت قرود فرانك سويسري زي ما قلنا في
الاول كنت بتدفع حوالي اثنين سلوتي بس
مقابل كل فرانك سويسرا دلوقت مضطر تدفع
4.7 زوتي مقابل الفرانك الواحد وبالتالي
اصبحت قيمه العديد من الرهون العقاريه
السويسري اكثر من قيمه العقاري الاساسي
نفسه في حين ان الطبيعي ان العقارب بيزيد
ثمنه بمرور الوقت
وقمت بتكون اكبر من اجمالي قيمه الاقساط
بتاعت رهن العقاري ولكن اللي حصل هنا هو
العكس يعني انا كاشرف في 2008 مثلا اشتريت
بيت ب 300 الف زلاطي لكن كنت واخد قرده
مقوم بالفرنك السويسري دلوقت قيمه رهن
العقاري نفسه وصلت ل 500 و 600,000 سلطي
في حين ان لو جيت ابيع البيت نفسه علشان
اسدد القرض هيجيب لي حوالي 400,000 زلطي
وده مبلغ اقل من قيمه الرهن العقاري
وبتكلم المنازل للاصحابها اخذوا قروض رهن
عقاري علشان يشتروها بقت من الناحيه
الماليه عند الوتر او تحت الماء بلغه
الناس بمجرد ما انكشفت الورطه لاصحابر هنا
العقاريه بالفرنك السويسري لا ونفسهم فيها
بعد 2015 بدات الاحتجاجات في الدول
المختلفه وهنا دخلت الحكومات على الفور في
العديد من البلدان لوضع قيود على اسعار
الصرف في وقت السداد بتاع اقساط الرهن
العقاري او تحويل القروض للعمله المحليه
كان من اوائل الدول اللي انتبهت للكارثه
دي المجر لما اجبره البنوك في 2014 على
تحويل ما قيمته 12 مليار دولار من القروض
بالعملات الاجنبيه للعمله المحليه وهي
الفورنت المجري بعدها بدات الحكومات في
كرواتيا وكوبرس والجبل الاسود ورومانيا
وصربيا نشوفوا حلول المشاكل دي مين بقى
اللي فضلوا يتاخروا لحد ما الوضع انفجر
عندهم مؤخرا بالضبط كده البولنديين بولندا
سمحت بتفك مشكله الفرانك سويسري لحد ما
وصلوا لنتيجه الحاليه ومن 2015 لحد 2019
الحكومه البولنديه كان يدها مرتعشه وخايفه
من عدم استقرار القطاع المصري وفي نفس
الوقت البنوك كان لها نفوذه وسطوه
وبالتالي الحكومه ما قدرتش تحسم المشكله
دي زي باقي الدول الثانيه لحد ما جينا في
2019 لما مجموعه من المفترضين بالفرانك
السويسري في بولندا رفعوا دعوه قدام محكمه
العدل الاوروبيه في الاقسم برج بوجود
ممارسات قروض غير عدله وتعمل بث في الدعوه
في ثلاثه اكتوبر 2019 والمحكمه
قرار في صالح حامل الرهن العقاري بعدها
طبعا بدات البنوك الجولنديه تنحاز لمشتري
المنازل وتحكم لصالحهم واتحمل البنك فوائد
قرض رهن العقاري بالفرنكسوس وده شجع باء
المختاردين انهم يرفعوا الاف الدعوه
القضائيه قدام المحاكم لحد ما بقت معركه
قضائيه ضخمه في بولندا بين حاملين الرهن
العقارب الفرنك السويسري من ناحيه وبين
البنوك التجاريه البولنديه الناحيه
الثانيه طبعا لسه لم تحسن بشكل نهائي حتى
اللحظه دي ولكن حامله رهن العقاري هم اللي
بيكسبوا في المحاكم على حساب البنوك اللي
بدات تعاني وتحقق خسائر بسبب القصه دي
المسؤولين والمصرفين بيحذروا من انهيار
بعض البنوك لو استمر حامله رهن العقاري في
كسب معاركهم القضائيه قدام البنوك جاك
جاسترو ذا سكي رئيس هيئه الرقابه الماليه
كائن اف بولندا بيقول ان انا من وجبه
دلوقت ان ارفع العلم الاحمر لان التظاهر
بانه كل حاجه تمام هيكون ليه عواقب
ماساويه وبحس القدام انهم يشوفوا التاثير
الاوسع على احكامهم على الاقتصاد البولندي
لو البنوك انهارت بسبب الاحكام دي وبيقول
ان حمايه المستهلك بقت دلوقتي زي الثعبان
اللي بياكل ذيله وفي النهايه العملاء دول
هم هم اللي هيدفعوا ثمن الفوضى اللي هتحصل
ولكن بعيدا عن كلام جستروسكى في الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه في شرق وسط اوروبا بتضع ضغوط
على الحكومات وتحديدا الحكومه البولنديه
وبتكبرهم ياخذوا قرارات في صالح المواطنين
اللي بيعانوا من ارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه
معدل التضخم في شهر اكتوبر اللي فات وصل
في بولندا لاعلى مستوى له 26 سنه عند
17.9% وده طبعا كان مدفوع بارتفاع اسعار
المواد الغذائيه والطاقه ودخلنا البنك
المركزي البولندي يرفع في اسعار الفائده
من اول السنه بنتكلم عن سبع مرات متتاليه
رفع فيهم المركز البولندي اسعار الفائده
لحد ما وصلها لسته فصل 75% بعد كانت اورده
الصفر في الشهور الاخيره من السنه اللي
فاتت وده بقى بالاضافه لوجود انتخابات في
بولندا السنه الجايه وبالتالي الحكومه
اليمنيه كانت حريصه على ارضاء الناخبين
وكاس بعصواتهم فاصدرت قرار قسم وسط البنوك
البولنديه اكثر ايه هو القرار ده بقى في
شهر يوليو اللي فات فرضت الحكومه
البولنديه حصر على سادات اقساط الرهن
العقاري وبالتالي القرار هيسمح للمفترضين
بتعليق المدفوعات بتاعه خروجهم العقاريه
لمده ثمان شهور مقسمين على اربع شهور
السنه دي واربع شهور السنه الجايه الفين
23 وده لمساعدتهم والتخفيف عنهم بسبب
اعباء التضخم وبالتالي البنوك هتتحمل
تكلفه تاجيل السداد لمده ثمان شهور وده
زود الضغوط عليها وعمك خسارها طبعا
مصرافيين في البنوك بيقولوا ان الحكومه
اليمنيه عملت كده لتعزيز فرصها في الفوز
بالانتخابات الوطنيه السنه الجايه وده على
حساب البنوك اللي بيتم استغلالها
واستخدامها
حساب شعبيه بين الناخبين من هنا بدات بنوك
كثير تتعرض لانكشاف كبير في دلوقتي
347,000 قرض بالعمله السويسريه في
الميزانيات العموميه بتاعه البنوك قيمتهم
مجتمعين
14.3 مليار فرنك سويسري والوضع ده ترك بعض
البنوك على شفا لانغيار وبالفعل سقط واحد
منهم في شهر سبتمبر اللي فات وهو بنك جت
النوفل عاشر اكبر بنك في بولندا واللي كان
بيعاني بقى له ست سنين من الخساير بسبب
بيع منتجات الرهن العقاري على المخاطر
وكانت محفظه من القروض فيها تعرض كبير
للفرنك السويس بنتكلم عن ان ربع محفظه
خروجه كانت وبالتالي كان بيعاني من دعاوى
قضائيه بخصوص هرمون عقاريه بالفرنسي وكان
بيخسرها طبعا لصالح المختار دي زي ما وضحت
وجاءت ضرب التاجيل مدفوعات الخروج
العقاريه قضت عليه وبالتالي الطاره البنك
المتعثر للدخول في اكبر عمليه اعاده هيكله
عمليه من قبل او اختلاف مكون انتمن بنوك
بولنديه بالاضافه لصندوق الضمان المصرفي
الحكومي البولندي لمنع فوضى ماليه بدات
تتشكل خطه الانقاذ بتاعه البنك هتكلف
المنقذين دول 2.2 مليار دولار خطه الانقاذ
دي بالمناسبه تعتبر الاكبر في بولندا منذ
الحقبه السوفيتايه طب ليه كميه البنوك
الكثيره دي بالاضافه لصندوق الضمان
المصرفي دخل وشيلوا البنك اللي هو ده
ببساطه علشان تكلفه الانقاذ تتوزع على
الجميع وما يشيلهاش بنك واحد المهم بعد ضخ
مبلغ الانقاذ ده هتستولي الثمن بنوك صندوق
الضمان المصرفي على اصول البنك المتعثر
وهيبداوا يبيعوا فيها في مده لن تتجاوز
ثلاث سنين وفقا للقانون سالي رئيس التنفيذ
اللي بانك بيقول ان لو المحاكم فضلت ان
هذا للمستهلكين في بولندا واوروبا الشرقيه
فتداعيات المحتمله هتكون اسفه وده ممكن
يدفع ما يوصل لخمس بنوك ثانيه لحافه
الانهار بالاضافه لكل اللي فات ده
هنلاقي بعض الخبراء بحذروا من الانفجار
اخر اكثر قوه مدفون تحت القطاع المصرفي في
بولندا مقارنه ويطلع للسطح السنه الجايه
لما الحكومه تبدا الاصلاح المخطط له من
فتره بخصوص نظام الفائده الداخلي المعمول
به بين البنوك في ورثه واللي اسمه وبر وده
نظام زي نظام لايبر اللي كان معمول به في
لندن ولكن بعد فضيحه ماليه تضمنت احتيال
بين البنوك سنه 2012 تم استبداله بسعر
معتمد على معاملات السوء بعد ما تم الكشف
عن تامر واحتيال من بعض البنوك للتلاعب
بسعر الفائده بينهم وده خلى السلطات
الماليه في جميع انحاء العالم تعمل عمليه
تدقيق في معايرها الخاصه وتتحول للحسابات
القائمه على معاملات فعليه ويبدو ان
الحكومه البولنديه بعد ما شافت العك اللي
حصل مع قروض الفرنك السويسري بتجري علشان
تستبدل في اسرع وقت ممكن
بقى مرعوبين من تكرار سيناريوهات الكوارث
الماليه اللي حصلت قبل كده احد المحامين
حاطين في دعاوي وراء هنا العقاريه اسمه
كوزجو كل شركته القانونيه فازت ب 60 قضيه
رهن عقاري من 2020 ورافعه 600 قضيه ثانيه
بيقول ان هايبر تم انشائه بطريقه مشابهه
لليبر ايه اللي يمنع ان يكون في نفس مشكله
لايبر يقصد وجود احتلال بين البنوك
البولنديه بخصوص سعر الفائده الداخلي
بينهم يعني وبيقول لو بصينا حوالينا
هنلاقي دول كثير بيتعرض فيها على الناس
رهن عقارب سعر فائده ثابت ولكن ده مش
موجود في بولندا ابدا طب ليه لان البنوك
البولنديه في رايه بتكسب اكثر من سعر
الفائده المتغير لانها قادر على التحكم في
مستوى السعر المعياري المصرفيين بيقولوا
ان لو المحكمه اقتنعت بالحجره دي والغت
العقود في وايبر فالتاثير على البنوك
البولنديه هيكون كاريس
التنفيذ السابق لبنك بيجي كي بيقول ان لو
ده حصل فلان بولندا هتواجه ازمه زي ازمه
اوائل التسعينات لما حصل عمليات دمج كثيره
في القطاع المصرفي لتجنب انهيار المؤسسات
الاضعف بسبب القروض المتعثره بالتاكيد ما
حدش يعرف على وجه اليقين اللي هيواجه
الاقتصاد البولندي في الشهور الجاي اخلونا
نتابع ونشوف انا كده خلصت كلامي لان مش
عايز اطول عليكم وكالعاده في نهايه الحلقه
عندي سؤال لحضراتكم خلونا نكشف التعليقات
تفتكروا ايه اكثر قطاع مصرفي ضعيف وهش في
الوطن العربي وايه السبب وهل ممكن نشوف
السيناريو البولندي في الوطن العربي هتابع
اجاكم كلها في التعليقات وما تنسوش تشوفوا
الادوات المتخصصه اللي بتقدمها بس واللي
بيحتاجها كل متداول محترف ويا ريتها من
الحلقه دي هتعملوا لايك وشير وتشتركوا في
القناه زي ما اتفقنا وما تنسوش تحكموا
لاصحابكم وحبايبكم عندنا يمكن نستفيد سلام
[موسيقى]